Match on a stick to hydrogen.
Big bang coming. Ready?
yep, here we go...
Hydrogen it the lightest element. And it's also a very
abundant element. You find it throughout the universe.
It's in stars, in the space between stars, and of course on Earth.
So here is our little Hindenburg, yes? A nice shinny balloon
with a very very flammable coating. We are just going to
pop it on to the cylinder and  fill it up with
a blast of Hydrogen. You can probably hear it
hissing an fizzing in the bottle there.
I think that it's also part of one of the most complex and interesting
molecules that exist. And that's water.
And there is still so much that we don't understand about water.
And as time goes on I think water will become
more and more important.
Ok, so there's our balloon, and as you can see it's quite floating.
Yes? So you got to keep  hold of it...
Or you lose it, you know?
Hydrogen is part of water because water has the formula H2O.
So you can look at it  as the Oxide of Hydrogen,
or the Hydride of Oxygen. But it is the Hydrogen
that is particularly important. And it's interaction with
Oxygen in the molecule.
The other thing with Hydrogen, which really fascinates chemists
is that it has an isotope Deuterium, which weighs twice as much,
which is an enormous difference in mass.
So by doing the same experiment with Deuterium instead of Hydrogen,
you can get very different effects. Reactions go faster
or reactions go slower depending what the role of the
Hydrogen or Deuterium is.
Oh fantastic...
Apart from their weight, they would look much the same.
Heavy water, D2O looks just the same as water H2O,
but it has a slightly different boiling point.
Slightly different freezing point. But if you start measuring
its properties, for example looking the way that
it absorbs infra red light, the way that molecules
react with it, then it turns out to be very different.
The difference between the isotopes, is that in Hydrogen the nucleus
contains just one Proton, And the, and Deuterium, the nucleus
contains both a Proton and a Neutron.
The Neutron has the same mass and the Proton,
at least within, for these purposes, and so the Neut... the nucleus of
the Hydrogen weighs half that of Deuterium.
There is a third isotope of Hydrogen called Tritium, which has
one Proton and two Neutrons, and that's radioactive.
So what we've got here, we got this balloon
full of Hydrogen and the air around it is full of Oxygen.
A little bit of Nitrogen in there, but the Oxygen,
that's the magic stuff. So it forms a really nice
intimate mixture, and what we are going to do is we are going to
offer it a match. We are going to see if it gets popped.
Match on a stick to Hydrogen.
Big bang coming...
you ready? Yep, here we go.
Captions by www.SubPLY.com